[Musique]
en slalom classique le squer déclenché
lui même le chronomètre seul en piste
il se concentre sur sa technique la
nouvelle épreuve par équipes est une
course explosive avec l'adversaire dans
l'angle mort
ce quelle faculté de temps mais c'est
pour gagner démonstration avec l'ex
membre de l'équipe canadienne
ève routhier
deux équipes avec chacune quatre skieurs
qui s'affrontent dans une série de duels
où chaque victoire vaut un point
le parcours est minimaliste une
vingtaine de portes et un ou deux sauts
une course aux allures de sprint
notamment au départ ou temps de réaction
est déterminant pendant le compte à
rebours
la clé est aux aguets puis c'est
l'explosion
en une demi seconde la skieuse se tire
vers l'avant avec une force qui peut
atteindre la moitié de son poids
elle défie les jambes pour damien au
caire puis elle pousse sont déployés
redirige cette impulsion vers le bas une
fois en piste
la claque enchaîne les virages au rythme
d'un par seconde
ces transferts de poids et exige à la
fois souplesse et équilibre
en début de virages la force centrifuge
augmente
l'athlète se replie sur elle-même la
forme parabolique 10 qui leur permettent
plié et d'accumuler l'énergie en sortie
de courbe cette énergie est de la
skieuse à rebondir pour attaquer le
prochain virage pour maximiser la
vitesse son centre de gravité doit
suivre la trajectoire la plus courte
possible et ce qui eu
suivent la trace est plus là au total
les jambes parcours dans une plus grande
distance que le haut du corps
[Musique]
en course difficile de jeter un oeil sur
la personne en l'écoutant on peut
deviner sa position et s'il devance il
faut prendre des risques
l'une des tentations s'est négocié des
virages trop serré en slalom classique
les athlètes ont d'habitude des piquets
simple qu'on peut rabattre avec le corps
les postiers coton d'appel mais dans
l'épreuve par équipes
les deux piquets sont reliés entre eux
l'ensemble est plus rigide un impact à
60 kilomètres à l'heure ralentir l
athlète
la plupart d'entre eux choisissent de
garder leurs distances
quitte à changer la trajectoire
dans cette épreuve où chaque centième de
seconde peut coûter un point c'est la
somme des performances individuelles qui
donne la victoire à une équipe et qu'ils
procurent aux athlètes une sensation
unique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]